a report this morning links Donald
Trump's campaign chairman to alleged
corruption in Ukraine officials tell the
New York Times that a pro-russia
political party set aside millions in
undisclosed cash payments designated for
Paul Manafort now mana fork denies that
he got any such payment our major
Garrett is looking at the newest
headache for the Trump campaign manger
good morning good morning Paul metaphors
ties to Viktor Yanukovych the
pro-russian former president of Ukraine
are well documented but new details
about the amount of money designated for
man afford by a Yanukovych's political
allies are likely to amplify Donald
Trump's claims he's facing media bias
according to the New York Times twelve
point seven million dollars was
earmarked for Paul Manafort by the
pro-russian political party of his main
client former ukrainian President Viktor
Yanukovych from 2007 to 2012
that's according to a so-called black
ledger analyzed by ukrainian
anti-corruption investigators who
believe it documents quote an illegal
off-the-book system whose recipients
also included election officials this
morning mana Ford issued a statement
denying it I have never received a
single off-the-books cash payment as
falsely reported by the New York Times
nor have I ever done work for the
government of Ukraine or Russia the
suggestion that I accepted cash payment
is unfounded silly and nonsensical as
Trump prepares to deliver a major speech
on terrorism in Ohio today the Clinton
campaign called the news troubling
adding Trump has a responsibility to
disclose manna forts and all other
campaign employees ties to Russian or
pro-kremlin entities I'm running against
the crooked media that's whatever
the report provides more ammunition for
Trump's ongoing clash with the New York
Times we have a newspaper that's failing
badly a real garbage their garbage it's
a garbage paper maybe we'll start
thinking about taking their press
credentials away from them beyond the
media bashing Trump is setting up
another excuse for losing voter fraud
the only way we can lose in my opinion I
really mean this Pennsylvania as if
cheating goes on Trump called for
volunteer election monitors go around
and look and watch other polling places
and make sure that it's a hundred
percent fine Democrats have carried
Pennsylvania and six straight
presidential elections there are nearly
1 million more registered Democrats
there now than Republicans
mathematically undercutting Trump's
claims that fraud could tip the balance
Trump will try yet again to refocus his
campaign today with that
counterterrorism speech at Youngstown
State University Charlie thanks major